[Music]
a marine corps veteran
followed and harassed by antifa just for
trying to open a dialogue with these
protesters in portland
their answer violence host of the reuben
report dave rubin joins me now with
reaction to that and more all right dave
thanks for being with us now
i understand that this gentleman for
more than 50 nights
gabriel johnson a retired marine 48
years of age
had been kept awake by the sound of the
rioting and the explosions taking place
outside his window and after two months
of living in fear
um he said that he decided to go out
and he said at that point i had counted
82 explosions that night that thought
somebody has to do something so he
decides that he wants to go out and
start talking to people
it didn't end well what can you tell us
about it yeah well there's so much
interesting stuff here because you know
everyone can sort of feel this split
that we have in the country right now
whether you want to call it democrat
versus republican
left right conservative liberal whatever
it is but i think there's something that
really underlies that which is
people that are willing to talk
and challenge their beliefs and engage
in
and people who just believe they are
right because
they believe it and that's good enough
in and of itself
and and damn the other people and i
think we're seeing a lot of this and
this is a really
uh perverse example of it because this
poor guy was followed home and
everything else
and all he wanted to do was converse
with these people um i
you know what's happening here also is
that the more
that the progressive mayor in portland
and seattle
los angeles more that they just
allow any want because we know they can
attack federal buildings you can stop
cars in streets you can attack police
officers you can light things on fire i
mean the litany of things
is endless the more they allow that to
happen well then
what they're also saying is the line of
what's acceptable
will just keep moving so why not follow
someone home why not attack someone in a
restaurant
or attack their car or or whatever else
you want to do
and i think what what falls beneath that
really is just that
we are if we're going to remain in a
civil society which i certainly hope we
are and i know you'd like to and all
your viewers want us to
uh we better start putting some lines in
the sand and saying this is
not going to be tolerable anymore and i
think trump's basically trying to do
that which is why
he's bringing in uh the feds because
these guys just won't do anything in
their own cities
but but but but dave just so you know i
mean the feds i mean
we're not talking about a whole lot of
them you know it's just the feds to
watch the federal courthouse
you know they have an obligation they sh
they're required
and then in all of these joint task
forces
but you know the truth is that since
there's
the so-called bail reform they let these
guys out as soon as the police make the
paperwork
that's assuming the police make an
arrest i mean
anarchy is here dave and my concern is
if they're following this guy a marine
corps
vet home what's the next step
okay there's no place to enforce the law
and what if they don't like what he said
what about this guy
uh who was shot in the head
because he had all of these pro-trump
signs in front of his business
now they're they're thinking that that
murder may have been politically
motivated
well this was the danger that i was
warning about for about five
years on my show because if you call
everybody a nazi if all of your
political opponents are nazis
and white supremacists and bigots and
racists and homophobes the worst
things that we can come up with well
then it won't just be enough to
to defeat them in the battle of ideas of
course violence will be okay and now the
bizarre part here
is that these same people uh who
seemingly are for violence or not
seemingly we know they're for violence
they also will tell you words are
violent so certain words apparently are
too dangerous to them but then violent
that really is the the danger of this
entire movement
it's not based in something that we can
build the society around if you want to
talk about any of the issues that they
want to talk about whatever they believe
okay see all sorts of people across the
political spectrum that will talk to you
uh but if your answer is we're gonna all
right yeah we're gonna burn everything
down people won't
cut you off dave all right dave rubin
thanks for being with us tonight
we'll be right back if you're looking
for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch
full interviews on a variety of topics
watch our full episode playlist all
right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell